Now TCP serves many applications well, but others want
to handle the problems of liability and flow control in
their own way. For this, they often use the
User Datagram Protocol or UDP, which is much simpler. The
header that gets attached to the payload includes only
the source and destination ports, the length of the data,
and a check sum to help detect data corruption.
There's no initial handshake or enforced mechanism for the order
of packets, they're just fired across the network. When
is UDP used? Well, if you have a very reliable
local network, then there's no need for the reliability or
out-of-order protections of TCP. All those acknowledgements would just be
wasted bandwidth. You would rather have the lower overhead
of the smaller UDP header and protocol. Streaming applications, where
it is more important to be on time than to
be right, prefer UDP. Think of voice over IP. A
user would much prefer a temporary degradation in the quality
of sound to incurring a delay, which makes conversation difficult.
If a packet is dropped, we might want to simply
say that it is too late and not bother trying
to incorporate its data. Similarly for video, a user would
much prefer an occasional low quality frame to having the
video intermittently start and stop, but with a perfect picture.
UDP tends to be more popular for these types of applications.